hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
simplified online tools for crispr cast
9 gene editing design and confirmation
my name is louise baskin and i'll be the
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
we encourage you to participate by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do this you just simply type them
into the ask a question box and click on
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you can also use this to submit any
technical issues as well if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing the presenter
so i'd now like to welcome our speaker
dr matthew polling he's a product
manager for genome editing at thermo
fisher scientific
and matt you can go ahead and begin
fantastic thank you luis all right i
will go ahead and get started with
today's presentation
so for today's agenda we've got four
main topics that we're going to cover
we're going to do a quick review of
genome editing and kind of how the
mechanisms of action happen at the
molecular level
and how we're going to be kind of tying
these tools together to
allow you know users at the bench to
have more successful gene editing
experiments
the first tool we'll talk about is our
true design genome editor
which is our design platform that pulls
all of these reagents together into a
nice clean package and makes genome
editing much simpler
for life scientists we'll then come back
and talk a little bit about how we can
confirm successful edits
using sanger sequencing and the tools
that we've developed to help that
workflow
and then we'll kind of uh wrap up by
doing a demonstration of the seek
screener gene editing confirmation app
um as well as kind of our some wrap up
and closing comments and then take the
questions from the audience and to go
ahead and get started we'll
we'll do our review of genome editing
and at the most basic
level when we really kind of simplify
this down to cartoons
ultimately what we're trying to do when
genome editing occurs is we've got a
piece of double-stranded dna that's
represented by those red lines
and some sort of engineered nuclease
that's going in and cleaving that dna in
a specific locus
this engineered nuclease can be crispr
cas9
that's kind of become the most popular
variant of this
but these fundamentals can also apply to
systems like crispr cast 12
or tall effector nucleases or zinc
fingers nucleases as well
but ultimately depending no matter what
enzyme system you're choosing
what we're trying to do here is go in
and cause specific double-stranded
breaks
of this dna now when dna is broken in
this manner the cells attempt to repair
it and attempt to repair it rather
quickly
broken dna is generally not a very
favorable physiological condition
and these repair mechanisms are always
faithful and
have opportunities for incorrect repair
to occur
and when this happens we can end up with
gene knockouts
by mechanisms of non-homologous end
joining that can be imperfect
we can get frame shifts or premature
stop codons occurring
which will disrupt open reading frames
and disrupt the functional proteins
these will be used to create knockout
cell models or if you're doing something
like a crispr library screening
this is generally the main genomic
readout that you're looking for
and then you'll be screening against any
kind of phenotypic changes that might
occur
the second pathway for this is going to
be my homology directed repair or hdr
and this occurs when a donor molecule is
provided in excess during the reaction
and during the repair process in the
cell these zoners generally have left
and right homology arms
that align around the flanking or excuse
me that will flank that edit site
and allow them to be incorporated into
the genome at that break point
and scientists will use this to create
you know kind of reporter genes or
fusion proteins
we'll do an example here in this
presentation about like adding a gfp
to the act b gene we can also do this to
go in and change
specific nucleic acid sequences like
making snip changes
either correcting snips or introducing
snips to mimic disease models and this
can be a very powerful tool to make very
specific changes
to the genome and for either of these
examples
you ultimately need three sets of
materials to have a successful
experiment
the first is going to be that specific
and efficient nuclear system
the second is going to be a repair
template with that desired change if
you're doing knock-ins you obviously
need to be providing that donor molecule
or providing that
template at the time of the editing is
occurring
and then lastly it's going to be a
method to deliver all of these materials
into your cells we need to be able to
kind of package this
and deliver this effectively into the
nucleus
now like we talked about the most
popular version of
this that we see you know kind of in the
life science community
is obviously going to be the crispr cast
9 system
you know over almost the last 10 years
this has kind of blown up and
really advanced our ability to do genome
editing successfully
because of this rna-guided dna nuclease
system
if you look at kind of our green bean
picture on the right hand side there
we've got our cas9 protein
and our guide rna molecules being the
two main components
this is adapted from a bacterial immune
response pathway
kind of from that adaptive immune
response system
where bacteria would try to prevent
phage infections and have specific
nucleases designed against those various
infections
and what we're able to do here with this
rna guided system
is break it down into kind of usable
parts
such as our cas9 protein or and the
duplex of the crispr rna and the tracer
molecules we know we use those as single
guide rnas
in most experiments but ultimately we're
able to take these parts combine them
together and deliver them into cells
to have successful editing when
thinking about designing these
experiments we also have to take into
consideration
some of the context specific sequences
and for streptococcus pyogenes cas9
which is the most common one
that we work with at thermo fisher
scientific we're looking at
a protostas or a json motif or a pan
that's an ngg
and that's going to become important
when we talk about how we analyze
and look for possible binding sites and
possible cutting sites
it's important to keep in mind that the
cast 9 system produces blunt-ended dna
breaks some of the other systems like
cast 12
or tall effector nucleuses will create
staggered cuts
but for today's presentation of the
tools we're talking about we're going to
be really looking at those those
blunt-ended breaks and how they're
formed
how that can be advantageous and how we
look for that from a sequencing
perspective
and then lastly you know when we think
about how actually one will do this in
the lab what materials they need at the
bench
we're looking at you know using these
either as a plasmid or as
mrnas made by in vitro transcription or
synthetically
or combining those with a recombinant
protein to do an rnp format using a
recombinant cas9 protein
and a single synthetic guide rna
now from the thermo fisher perspective
and how we look and want to be enabling
scientists that work with us
is we ultimately want to be helping you
know their goal of getting any edit into
any cell line
and to that end we try to break it down
into kind of three basic steps for this
design deliver detect and how can we
support scientists wanting to move from
this design
to delivering these into their cells and
then detecting if they've had successful
outcomes
and for today's presentation we're
really going to focus on kind of the
first and the third pillow here
uh the design piece how do we design you
know the proper materials
to ensure success have successful
knock-ins
and then how do we go about detecting
that from a sequencing perspective
we do have a number of presentations
also available via lab roots on our
website around our delivery platforms
such as the lipofectamine reagents or
the neon electroporation system
and we have additional assets available
to talk about that if you're interested
now from the design perspective we're
going to talk a lot about guide rnas and
donors but it's also important to talk
about
the cas9 nuclease in having the most
efficient enzyme possible
for that and to that end we do have our
true cas9 enzyme this is a next
generation protein that has high editing
efficiencies
and i'm not going to spend too much time
on this but ultimately you know you want
to be starting
experiments off with something that's
going to have very high efficiencies and
be
able to be effectively delivered into
your cell types
using something like a plasmid can be
effective for some examples but
ultimately we've shown you know in
numerous examples that delivering a cas9
protein
can lead to higher editing efficiencies
and overall higher
experience overall higher success and
experimental outcome
and that's why we generally recommend a
cas9 protein for all of our protocols
and approaches here and you'll see that
as we go through the tool as well
now to think about designing experiments
here and designing those sequences
you know it can be misleading to think
that you can just use
any guide rna for any crispr experiment
and get success
because not every guide rna is actually
appropriate and not all
rnas are kind of created equally you
know the
stem basically the the basics of a guide
rna will be
the same from experiment to experiment
but that seed and spacer region can be
different
for each experiment and those can
significantly affect the outcome
and to kind of break it down we're
looking at two main variables here
one is the efficiency how well is this
guide rna going to target and cleave
that locus
how well and how can we predict these
outcomes
uh in silico before even needing to go
to the bench
you know how close you know what's the
gc composition of that region
what kind of repeats are there is there
possibility of any secondary structure
because when we use inefficient guides
it can lead to you know kind of wasted
resources and time
and ultimately frustration because of a
lack of success so you want to be going
in when using something
where you know you're going to have that
good efficiency and high likelihood of
success
the second piece of this is off targets
so while we assume that guide rnas are
going to be specific
for the locus that we've designed them
to we
and others have often found that
off-target effects can occur
even you know even if you don't have
perfect base pairing you know some
single base substitutions can still even
lead to
editing at unintended loci and when we
don't
take this under consideration or control
for it you can actually disrupt other
major genes and significantly
affect your outcomes and confound
results it can be very
difficult to make meaningful
interpretations from the data
and if you're an investigator thinking
about going into clinical applications
this can be even more important
as these off targets could be genotoxic
and ultimately you know damages cells
that you're editing
or oncogenic and creating unintended you
know cancerous phenotypes and so
off targets can be a very important
consideration as well
and we can address that within silico
predictions
and so ultimately you know how does one
contend with this
um it's really using you know kind of
the the knowledge from these data sets
to build an in silico prediction model
and at the basic level how this will
work is that we'll look at a nucleic
acid sequence here we've got about 51
bases
on the screen here uh you know of our
double stranded dna
and the first thing we'll do is we'll
look for those pam sites we'll try to
identify that
ngg sequence on the top and the bottom
strand
that are going to be suitable for
streptococcus
pyogenes cas9 and guide rna binding
we'll take those sequences and we can do
alignments on them and we can start to
rank them
and then we can ultimately do binding
and off target predictions
using our software here so we can go
through and make predictions of
you know these guide rnas are going to
have really high scores we think that
they're going to be highly efficient
and then look at those number of off
target effects and we can do kind of
this forced ranking
and weighted prioritization of binding
and possible off targets
and then ultimately provide
recommendations to the user as to which
ones we think would be suitable
given their experimental inputs
now the other molecule that's going to
be important for this as well especially
if you're going to be doing those
knocking experiments is the donor design
and for that we've also you know been
hit with a lot of questions on that end
as well of you know like how close
does you know that edit site need to be
to that
cut site you know how long do the
homology arms need to be
should we be using something that's
symmetrical or asymmetric should we be
using single stranded or double stranded
and ultimately we kind of you know end
up in the same general question of can
you help me design my donor i don't know
what i need to be doing here
and to that end we you know really the
the
the origin of the software that we built
here was really to help address this
problem
and we acknowledged that we needed to
establish kind of like consistent and
simple rules for this
make this design tool easy to use we
want to be helping
you know investigators you know who are
just beginning their journey as well as
our experts
so we need some sort of intuitive
interface that makes it that makes it
simple for everyone
and we want to make sure that this is
free and available to scientists
globally
and being from thermo fisher we have the
opportunity to do that with our cloud
platform and so we made this free
software available
on thermo fisher connect and i'll be
demonstrating that
and then you also might be thinking too
well like you know you've come up with
these rules but how do we know that they
work
and to that and we've actually published
in in a peer-reviewed journal
our design considerations for this you
know how do we need to be designing
donor molecules
to ensure success and make it as simple
as possible for users
and so we published just a few years ago
in the journal of biotechnology and this
article is available or is linked excuse
me
on our on our marketing page that i'll
be sharing and it is available uh
for anyone who wishes to go view it so
that information is available
as part of the resources so to that in
and some of the data from this
publication this is not an
exhaustive review of that but looked at
trying to understand the proximity of
these cut sites using a single stranded
donor
so across the top here we've got about a
70 base pair region
with position zero being marked as our
possible insertion and we're doing a six
base pair insertion
to repair gfp so ultimately when we get
successful insertion here
our cells will turn green and that is
our readout and so we see that we have
possible guide rnas from the minus 34
position all the way up to the plus 30.
and when we look at our cleavage events
across this entire span
we can see that we get a variety of
guide rna effectiveness
if we look at our percent zindale we're
averaging around 50
overall with some getting closer to 80
and others like our plus 21 guy being
you know
pretty poor less than 20 editing but
overall kind of across this range we've
got
you know kind of average outcomes here
from gene editing from a from an indel
perspective
but when we look at our ability to
repair
gfp to have the successful six base pair
insertion that's going to allow that
protein to be functional
we really only see success when we're
within
10 bases of that insertion site so
remember the insertion is at position
zero
and if we look from minus seven to plus
eight that's where we start to see
significant differences here
and we're seeing that gfp repair and
that knock-in rate actually start to go
up several fold and so if we kind of
think about this holistically you know
when we're flanking within 10 base pairs
of either side that's where we really
start to see this this effect and
improve
and even you know and you can also see
that there's a secondary issue here with
that plus three guide rna
that doesn't perform very well we
actually see that knock-in rate drops
significantly
and so kind of with these data and
supplementary data as well that i'm not
showing here
we kind of try to come up with some
guidelines and general rules and the
first being using
ensuring that your insertion site is in
within 10 bases of that dna break
and utilize kind of the highest cleaving
cas9 guide rna pairing
that's available for your design and
trying to
you know kind of ensure your success by
having those tools be complementary
um and and high efficiency
so to that end we kind of have our three
simple rules for genome editing
you'll kind of see a trend here where we
try to break things down into into three
things
design deliver detect our three simple
rules but ultimately we've got
break excuse me our first rule being
have your dna break less than 10 bases
of your desired edit site
ultimately wherever you want to be
causing that edit to occur you really
want to be using
a design that's within 10 bases of
either side of that edit site
because we really start to see the
performance drop off when we go outside
that range
and so we have rules in place to try to
keep you localized around that locus
to have that efficiency be the highest
the second is to use the most efficient
enzyme system possible so that'd be
using the highest scoring guide rna
available
it might be changing out your tool set
and considering something like tal
effector nucleases
if that will be predicted to be higher
editing than the crispr cast 9 system
and the last is use at minimum of 30
nucleotide homology arms we really
want to keep the system compact and easy
to use and we found that 30 nucleotide
homology arms
are sufficient to get high knock-in
editing and that really around designing
you know as close to that edit site as
possible is really going to be
delivering
the higher level of success and so so
using minimal homology arms
when using a donor can be a very
effective tool
so to that end what we've tried to do
here today or excuse me what we've tried
to do is uh
build our true design genome editor
platform
and this is a software that lives on
thermo fisher connect i'll be doing a
demonstration of that in just a moment
but what we ultimately want uh what
we're supporting our
users with is searching for their gene
of interest we've got five different
species in the software now
human mouse rat zebrafish and roundworm
allowing them to go
in and find the specific transcript that
they're looking for find the
amino acid and nucleic acid sequences
they want to modify and make those
specific changes
and then ultimately giving them a
complete design giving them the cas9
guide rna sequence giving them the donor
molecules so that they can have a
complete solution
and have a successful editing experiment
at the bench once they receive those
materials
so for our first example i want to talk
a little bit about how we support this
with fluorescent tagging
and what we have here is our true tag
donor dna system so this is our
our solution for doing kind of larger
insertions such as
tagging and the way that the system
works is that we
have n-terminal or c-terminal templates
that can be
customized to the locus of interest by
pcr
and so these templates are are provided
to the user and by a simple pcr reaction
we can add those homology arms which you
can kind of see in orange there
on our schematic to these donors and
make them specific for
that particular locus and a guide rna
and to this end we're able to get
editing efficiencies or excuse me get
high editing efficiencies and get up to
99 edited cells
using those resistance markers that are
built into the donors by applying
pyromycin or blastocyte and selection
we can really drive that cell population
uh to being greater than 90 percent
almost 99
edit itself and you can see an example
here and the upper right hand side of
some photographs
of a gfp tagged actin excuse me
gfp tag cells at the actin locus and
nice actin filaments actually being
stained
green from that gfp and endogenous gfp
in that system and then looking at the
graph from the lower right hand side
you can see how we were able to drive
that editing efficiency and that overall
edited population
to being greater than 80 percent
now the way that this is going to work
from kind of a textbook illustration
perspective
is that we have our single guide rna we
have our cas9 protein
we have our true tag donor that we've
customized by
pcr to our locus of interest
all being combined together with the
crispr max lipofectamine reagent
and once we create these little
lipid delivery vessels we'll be
transfecting them and delivering them
into the cell
these materials will be delivered into
the cytoplasm they'll be taken up by
nuclear import
and ultimately go in and modify the
genomic locus so we've got our cas9
going in and cutting the dna
we've got our donor molecule being
incorporated
at the locus of interest and then
ultimately leading to the expression of
a gfp tag protein as you can see there
in step seven
and so what we're trying to do is you
know again trying to
simplify this process and really provide
all of the design considerations and all
of the
the necessary materials for this to be
successful
up front in a single tool
and then again to kind of briefly go
over kind of the illustrations here of
how we use trutag
you know we start off with kind of a
basic donor where we then use left or
right homology arm pcr primers
to extend those out and make them
specific to the locus of interest
and this is an example of doing end
terminal tagging so doing it to kind of
the front end of the gene at the start
codon
or for c terminal tagging and doing it
at the the back end of the gene
near the stop codon as well and these
illustrations are available within the
true design tool
if you're looking to see more of them
and without any further ado
i'm going to go ahead and switch over to
my browser
for a demonstration of how to get into
the tool and how to use the software
so give me one second while i change my
screens
okay hopefully i am now sharing my
browser for all of you and we can go
ahead and look at where this tool lives
on thermofisher.com
so this page can be reached via
thermofisher.com
and this is our landing page page for
the true design software
when you first come to this page you'll
be greeted with a button that's in
bright red here that is to launch the
application
and then we also have a number of assets
available on this page as you scroll
down that speak to the capabilities of
the software
some screenshots of the workflow as well
as additional resources for getting
started
now for the sake of time i'm going to go
ahead and go straight into the tool by
clicking the launch the app button
this will go ahead and open a new window
for you
and then it will also then redirect you
to our thermo fisher connect login page
now if you have an account with
thermofisher.com already you can go
ahead and use that username and password
to sign in
if you don't have a login with us as of
yet
you can go ahead and create an account
with just a few steps and i'll
demonstrate that here when we click
create an account
so when we go ahead and do that we are
going to be just asking for
your first name last name and email
address to create an account you don't
need your full billing and shipping
information
um really just the basic logins that you
need to
to access a cloud tool so for this
example i will just use
a gmail address here oops if i can type
and then we'll go ahead and give a
strong password that no one can guess
and then the last thing we ask for you
is uh to say if you're interested in
receiving uh
informa more additional information from
us about our products and services
obviously we like to be able to reach
out um to all our scientists that we
support
but if you're not interested in
receiving uh email communications from
us go ahead and feel free to
click that no button and create an
account
we'll just take a moment to process
all right here looks like our
registration was successful
and what we can do at this point is you
can go ahead and complete the rest of
your institution info but you don't need
to do that at this stage
we can go ahead and go back to our true
design genome editor tab
click launch the app and then we'll go
ahead and be presented with the tool
once this page loads just give me one
second here
all right and as we're accessing our
thermo fisher connect platform for the
first time with this account that i just
made
we're going to be accepting our terms
and conditions of use for the platform
as well as specifically for the true
design software
all right now we are in true design and
we are ready to do our first experiment
so as you can see we're presented with
five different experiment options
gene knockout fluorescent tagging
insertion deletion and snip edit
for our insertions and deletions we are
limited to 30 bases
we are supporting designs of that
smaller side because we are trying to
keep everything contained with a within
a single
dna oligo and to that end we can support
up to 30 bases plus those homology arms
that i was speaking to
for this first example we'll do
fluorescent tagging
so i'll go ahead and select the button
and click next we'll then have our five
species to choose from we've got human
mouse rat
zebrafish and c elegans the round one
i'm going to go ahead and do the human
example
we can then search by gene symbol dna
sequence or chromosomal locus i'm going
to do gene symbol
and then what the tool will allow you to
do is it has some predictive text
recommendations so as i start to type in
act b to go for the actin b gene you'll
see that those lists start to refresh
and we can see that the first one on our
list here is that act b
gene we go ahead and search for that and
it'll pull all of the relevant
transcripts
for the actin b gene on ncbi
and so we can see we've got our
transcript here on the list we've got
our if we click on that hyperlink it'll
actually go ahead and take you
out to the ncbi sequence for your gene
so that you can cross-reference and
confirm that you're ultimately going to
be working with the right gene here
we know this is the right one and so
we're going to go ahead and select edit
so now that we're on our second step of
the software we're on our edit page
we now have a number of new features
available starting at the top of our
screen here
we have a topology map of the actb locus
we can see our introns kind of labeled
here we've got a very large exon 4 we've
got our exon 6 here
and if you click these plus minus
buttons you can kind of zoom in
and get better definition of this
topology
and so we can see here we've got kind of
our exon 2 we've got a little bit of an
untranslated region
our intron and the following exon if you
go below that the sequence editor is
going to be showing a detailed view of
what's in that blue box
and so we can see again here our
annotations for intron 1.
we can see our second exon here and
we've got a little bit of untranslated
region before this methionine of our
start codon
so for our tagging experiment we're
going to be doing
choosing from these pre-selected options
so the first thing that we're going to
choose is our n
or excuse me doing an n-terminal tag so
we're going to choose amino and terminus
we could also choose carboxy terminus if
that's the position you want to be
tagging
we're going to choose between our gfp or
rfp reporter and then we're going to
choose our blast
seeden or pyramic and resistance marker
once we have our selections
chosen the add tag button will turn red
and it'll go ahead and insert that
into our genome basically at that start
codon position so we can see our pure
gfp arrow here
right after that start codon and we can
see that summarized here on
our edit list if we want to go back and
make changes we can click this undo
button
and that selection will be taken out and
we could switch this over to rfp or
switch to the blast aside marker but
we'll keep with those initial selection
choices
and we add them in and then we'll go
ahead and click design
and this is where all the bioinformatics
fun part comes from on the back end here
so what the software is doing at this
point is it's scanning this region
looking for possible pam sites near that
edit site
if you recall we're trying to keep
everything within 10 bases
of our perspective edit site which is
going to be right after that start codon
once we've identified all of those guide
rna sequences we're going to start to do
blast alignments for them try to predict
where those off targets might be
what the prevalence prevalences of those
what the scores of those off targets
might be
to give an overall ranking and
recommendations of guide rna targets
once that's done the last thing it's
going to do is it's going to go ahead
and design
those forward and reverse primers for
those large knock-in donors
that will do that gfp knock-in for us
and so the software will kind of run
through and do all of this bioinformatic
power on the back end
using the thermo-fisher connect cloud
and then ultimately present the results
to us
and as you can see here we now have our
two possible guide rnas that were
identified being within 10 bases of this
insertion site
we can see our first one here has our
green check mark saying it's recommended
if i click on this row we can see it
showing up in
our sequence editor here the green box
being kind of that binding sequence
and the purple box being our pam site
we can see our score here of 95.9 so a
really nice high scoring guide rna
we've got nine possible off targets if i
click this hyperlink it'll show a pop-up
modal
that has all of those sequences uh and
possible off-target sites here
if you see one where it does have a zero
also in chromosome 7 this is actually
our on target site here
and basically showing that we are
successfully identifying our on target
locus
and then if we look at the far right
side of this table we're going to have
our fluorescent tagging primers with
that forward and reverse primers
that'll customize that donor template to
be for this actin
b locus you can see we've got a second
guide rna that came up here it does not
have our green check mark and that's
because we have a score of 35
even though it's a little bit closer to
our edit site
the gc composition here is considered
unfavorable
for editing efficiencies and ultimately
we get a score of 35 and this is really
not
the best choice to move forward with um
and we can see this guide rna as well
see that it's on the bottom strand by
selecting the row and it's highlighted
up here in the sequence editor
we're going to go ahead and select this
guy by checking our blue check mark here
and then we're going to go to our
summary page now on our summary page
we're going to have all of the design
inputs that were put in summarized for
you as well as some product selections
to
ultimately pull this all together
starting from our
top left hand side we have our guide or
excuse me our casino format
we have our true cut cas9 protein or our
crispr nuclease mrna
we have our single guide rnas or
synthetic guides and a 1.5 nanomole
scale
and then we also have our transection
reagent that crispr max region i was
speaking to earlier
that's going to be used to bundle this
all together and deliver this payload
into the cells
you can view your crispr designs and
donors in this little pop-up model so
we'll see we've got our act b
crispr number one we've got our sequence
here and then we've got that forward and
reverse primers being presented as well
we also have kind of our total product
summary here of everything that's needed
for this to be successful
and then we also have additional
products such as sequencing primers
which will come into play when we talk
about seek screener
in the second half of this presentation
as well as positive and negative
controls which are essential for for
properly
controlling for the experiment if you
wish to view the illustrations that i
showed earlier in the presentation the
powerpoint these are also available
within the software
and can be used for review or for
presentations you know lab presentations
are being saved for notebooks
and then the lastly is to export your
results and protocol and if you click
this button
you'll go ahead and have a download that
shows up in a save to your local disk
that'll have all of those gene editing
outcomes saved in a downloaded excel
file
for future reference so i'll just wait
for my excel to open up here
fantastic so you can see we've got our
our guide rna sequence here we've got
our forward and reverse primers
if we go to our gene editing design
information you can see all of the input
information
kind of our our specific locus the
transcript we're working with that gene
symbol
and kind of the last thing to call out
here is that we also have a
protocol helper so we have an overview
of the crispr max transaction protocol
as well as a complete transfection table
and then lastly if you're ready to move
forward and
acquire these materials you can click
add to cart and all of the materials
will be added to your thermofisher.com
cart
so let's go back and do another example
here real quick so instead of doing
fluorescent tagging
i'm going to go ahead and do a snip
change and for this example we're
going to do something in mouse now to
search for this gene
i'm going to actually use our dna
sequence search option
and what this allows you to do is to
enter a 500 to 200 base pair region
i'm going to copy this from my other
window that's off screen
i've got a i believe this is about 120
nucleic acid sequence
and we're going to go ahead and map that
sequence against the mouse genome and
it's pulling up the myostatin mouse
gene and so we see that that's our
transcript that we're looking for and
we're going to go ahead and edit that
now what's happened here is that since
we put in the sequence that corresponds
to exon 1
we're actually being delivered and
dropped into
that region of the mouse gene so we're
already centered on this part of exon
one
now what i'm going to be doing here is
i'm going to be selecting
this particular base at position
2008 6. oops let's see here i meant
selected didn't quite go there we go
and we're going to be doing a specific g
to t mutation here
that's actually going to be inserting
and converting this to a stop codon
so we've changed that into a stop codon
position here that will ultimately
disrupt the open reading frame of this
myostatin gene in the mouse
and so if we're doing this like in mouse
embryos we could be making you know kind
of those mice that have
excessive muscle formation can be kind
of an interesting model
for gene editing but we've got a single
stop here
and you know we maybe want to be
ensuring that we're really going to be
truncating this protein and have
absolutely no risk
of any possible read through so we might
do a second edit on top of this
and we'll do a secondary insertion right
after this stop codon we just put in and
we're going to put in
two additional stop codons so i'm going
to do tga and tga
i'm going to go ahead and insert that
and now we've got a
triplet of stop codons that have been
inserted at this secondary position so
again we did a snip change at this first
position
and then we've done a secondary six base
pair insertion at this secondary
position just three bases down
so this is a rather complex edit that
we're supporting here with the tool
and we'll go ahead and see what comes
out the other end in terms of guide rna
design and what our donors look like
so again we'll go ahead and click the
design button and the software will go
through
and do in this entire bioinformatic
analysis for us
looking at you know possible guide rna
sequences
possible off targets for that as well as
those donor molecules
and with that we'll let this run and i
will take a sip of water and catch my
breath
all right and there are our results for
this particular design
so we've got our two edits being
incorporated into our donor molecule
we have our single guide rna that's
being recommended here
it does meet our thresholds of being
suitable and getting that green check
mark
we've got an 85.8 score here we do have
a higher number of off targets
but since we're trying to do some very
specific changes here
this is going to be our best recommended
guide for this knock-in experience
for this knock-in experiment excuse me
again we can see the guide rna binding
site
relative to these insertion sites and we
can go ahead and select that to move
forward with
a little bit different for this view
since we're doing a snip change
when we go ahead and view our donors
we'll see our guide rna sequence here
excuse me
and then we'll also see that donor
molecule with those specific changes
being presented
as well and then we can also do the same
thing as well with this
where you can view your gene editing
experiment our illustration is revised
to reflect
these kind of snip insertion deletion
changes as well as export these results
to save them to your local disk
or you can add all of these products to
your thermo fisher.com cart
if you're ready to try them in the lab
yourself
with those two demonstrations i'm going
to go ahead and switch back to my
powerpoint
just give me one second while we load
that back up
all right now that we're back in the
powerpoint we'll review briefly
kind of the benefits for the true design
genome editor this allows users to
search for their gene of interest you
can go ahead and craft the specific
changes you're looking to do
and then ultimately kind of complete
your design and have a complete package
of materials to have a successful
editing experiment at the bench
again this can be found at
thermofisher.com true design
now once you've done this experiment you
need to think about how you're going to
go about confirming
it how are we going to actually
determine if these results
were successful and so we've delivered
cas9 and guide rna to our cells
we've made a pool of mutant clones but
ultimately
you know what's happening here we've
caused that double-stranded break and
we've had dna repair
occur but did we get the outcome that we
needed
and ultimately what happens here is
you'll end up with a pool of edited
cells you might be working in like a
24-well dish
and within that single 24 single well of
the dish
there's going to be a pool of various
editing outcomes that occurred you're
going to have some cells that might be
wild type you're going to have cells
that are going to be homozygous that
have both you know both alleles have the
correct edit
you might have cells that are only
heterozygous you know that have
one you know one allele corrected but
one allele different
and how are you going to kind of tease
those apart how are you going to
understand the editing efficiency
and so there's a need to do kind of a
pooled screening or do kind of a pooled
analysis
to verifying what kind of editing
efficiency what kind of outcomes you
have from that pool
of you know mixed population of cells
and then after that you'll need to go
into a clonal expansion step where
you're going to be kind of pulling out
either your
heterozygous your homozygous or your you
know kind of isogenic wild-type controls
for further analysis and so for this
clonal screening there's also a need to
understand kind of these various allelic
states
do we have the cells that are a wild
type in this population in this
particular world do we have ones that
have both alleles edited or just one
allele edited
was our clonal isolation protocol not
super clean and we have a contamination
where we have a mixed population of
cells here
even though we were trying to do single
clones and
the way that we can go about doing that
is actually through sanger sequencing so
sanger sequencing is actually pretty
straightforward process at this point
something that we've really optimized at
thermo fisher scientific
and what you're going to be doing is
doing a simple pcr reaction and a
cleanup
and then going through a site or excuse
me then going through a cycle sequencing
reaction
that's going to ultimately create the
various
lengths of dna for a sanger sequencing
run
that material gets further cleaned up
and then it's going to get run on a
genetic
analyzer through capillary
electrophoresis and
through that process we're able to do
specific base calls
to understand the nucleic acid sequence
as it gets run through that capillary
but kind of a new piece to this is doing
that data analysis
because it's actually not quite as
simple as i just
i just said so when you have your your
edited sample
and come that kind of comes out the
other end of the the capillary
electrophoresis system
if you look kind of to the right of our
that dashed line there where our double
stranded break occurs
you can start to see that the base calls
become kind of jar bold we kind of kind
of mix
peaks where we've got you know maybe
it's clearly an a
and some are maybe clearly a t but other
ones you can kind of see multiple base
calls coming through
and ultimately as you read across the
top you know we start to see more and
more degenerate base code
showing up as the reads here and this is
because ultimately when the dna repair
occurs we don't have kind of this unique
clean sequence to read anymore after
that break site after that edit site
and so how are we going to align and
interpret these results
and how can we do this from a software
perspective
well the the deconvolution of all of
these reads
has been done by a number of different
groups but we've been able to take that
base software
and expanded it to create it more to
make a more useful piece of software
for the genome editing scientist base
and so what we what most tools have is
kind of ability to do some primary
screening and kind of kind of do batch
mode analysis where they can take a lot
of samples
but they don't really have the ability
to support that secondary screening
workflow when you're
thinking about looking at clones and how
do you do that
these softwares can be pretty slow they
take a long time to analyze the data
and they don't really save the
information on the local disk it's
generally you load it to a website the
information's there
you need to capture a screenshot because
it's not going to be there when you come
back later
and so they're not connected to any kind
of data repository or ability to save
this
and so what we wanted to do with the
seek screener platform is kind of create
something that's going to add
additional value and additional excuse
me
be more user friendly for for the genome
editing
users and
one of the most common things that we
you know
we will get asked from from users is you
know kind of how does this compare to
next generation sequencing
are we seeing equivalent results can we
trust these results relative to next
generation sequencing
which you know has been kind of
considered you know the standard
uh for a lot of these outcomes but is a
much more labor intensive and
complicated process
and so we did some benchmarking here and
you can see that we've got some really
nice linearity
um in terms of editing efficiencies for
something for sanger sequencing across
the x-axis
versus ngs across the the y-axis there
giving us that we have some pretty good
confidence
in the editing outcomes that the that
this
finger sequencing tool can give us
and to that end we built out the the
seek screener gene editing confirmation
app
and trying to use kind of the same uh
look and feel
and uh intuitiveness that we have with
our thermo fisher connect platform
you know building a software that allows
for quick identification of successful
edits
we want something that's going to be
fast and accurate we wanted our
algorithm to be robust
to have that strong linearity with ngs
data which we use as our as our baseline
like i showed on the previous slide and
then having it kind of widely available
by having it on thermo fisher connect
you know having this be a platform that
that any investigator can access
with just a simple login like i
demonstrated before
and so again you know really wanting to
to have
you know multiple pieces of software and
having multiple solutions
to support you know life or excuse me
gene editing users here
and with that i'm going to go ahead and
switch back to my browser and we'll do a
demonstration of the seek screener
software
all right hopefully i am sharing my
browser again
and now we have our seek screener gene
editing confirmation app up
um as i'm still using that new account
that i just made for
the thermo fisher connect platform i'm
going to be accepting on
these uh terms of use in the eula and
we'll be saving this information
onto the thermo fisher connect platform
i'm going to go ahead and close this out
and we'll close the quick tips because
i'm going to show that to you
and kind of the way that this software's
set up is you're going to be able to
save your data into the platform
and we're going to be importing edited
samples as well as control file samples
here to be doing these comparisons in
these analysis
so the first thing i'm going to go ahead
and do is i'm going to go ahead and pull
up my data sets here so for our import
our edited samples
i'm going to be dragging in a folder of
samples here and this is going to have
six samples within it
and i'm going to go ahead and control
the matching control files for all of
those samples
and the software is going to go ahead
and take those ab1 files coming from the
genetic analyzer
and validating them and then presenting
these out basically these edited sample
files
in a table form here now we do need to
map these out so that they know which
control file they're going to match with
or which
guide rna was used for cutting this we
also have the option for
aligning and analyzing a donor sequence
as well so you're able to put in your
guide rna sequence
and a donor sequence and the tool will
take those under consideration
for predicting the editing efficiency
and doing that analysis
um the fastest way to do this for a lot
of samples is to go ahead and add or
upload a mapping file and i'm going to
go ahead and just do that from
my saved files here i'm going to go back
to
our primary sample here there we go
and we're going to go ahead and load
those files and so you can see that
using our mapping file here we've got
all of our various guide rnas that we're
testing here loaded up
we've got our match control files and
then we've got our sample files here
and we can go ahead and hit analyze and
now the software is going to go through
and you'll see how fast it is
to do all of these analyses and provide
us with meaningful outcomes
so when you end up on your results page
you'll be able to see kind of
at a quick view here kind of the
grading of the wells so basically how
we're scoring these
what plate it came from what well on
what plate it came from
how we've titled it whether we've
analyzed this as a knockout or a knock
in
those target sequences and then kind of
the main outcomes here are model fit
and our editing percentages and kind of
our frame shift editing
and then the last thing here being
diversity of edits or the number of
edits that have been identified in this
sample
starting off with our grade if we hover
over this you'll see that we have
recommendations for
you know kind of like ideal good or
needs review
ideal meaning samples that are going to
have you know very high confidence high
model fit scores high editing
efficiencies
we have very high confidence that the
sample that you're analyzing here was a
good knockout
and it's something that you could be
considering and propagating further
good knockout is kind of in that middle
ground with something where we have that
high editing efficiency our model fits
good
but it's not as high as kind of that
ideal knockout
model here the remaining ones are going
to be kind of in the
needs review something like a model fit
might not be great like if you look at
this one here
the sample four our model fit score is
.44 so we don't have a whole lot of
confidence that this reads these reads
were clean enough to make that call
and then the ones marked in w are going
to be wild type and we can see overall
we have either
very little to almost none editing
efficiency you know less than five
percent here this is basically a wild
type sample
and 0.77 here so we had very poor
efficiencies of this guy at rna
if you want to go in and look at any of
these examples you can just click on the
row
and it'll take you into an overview of
the plate map and this will be important
when we do the the clonal screening view
but really what i want to show you is
this indel frequency chart
and overall what you can see here is
that we are displaying out
bar charts of the predicted frequency of
that editing outcome in this sample
so you can see here that we've got you
know kind of
a plus one insertion contributing almost
65 percent
of the data that came out of the sample
we've got a minus 1 being about 15
and we've got some minor variants as
well that are also showing up
if we scroll down we can kind of see the
alignment here of our control
here's our break site in the dotted line
and then where this plus one insertion
here so we've got that plus sign here
and then here's how the rest of the
sequence is aligning
and then looking overall here for
basically anything over five percent
we have it highlighted here you know
kind of our plus one being the major
contributor
minus one being a secondary contributor
and kind of this -10
also being a tertiary contributor to
this editing efficiency
going across the top here we see our
model fit is 98
so this is a pretty strong linearity we
have high confidence in this data
our overall editing efficiency is going
to be 96.25 so that's the sum
of all of these variants basically that
are not zero
and then our percent frame shift which
is accounting for everything that's not
going to be a plus 3 or a minus 3.
so you know a plus 3 insertion might
have the same reading frame
as the wild type protein just with an
additional amino acid or a minus 3 might
just have removed a single amino acid
and so we're considering here you know
how this might be overall disrupting the
the reading frame and the
production of a functional protein and
then the last thing you can do here too
is you can look at the sequencing traces
oh there we go
rid of the quick tips here since you
have me demoing it for you
and we can see the actual traces that
came out of the genetic analyzer
and being able to see kind of how this
data you know kind of became
convoluted and kind of messy after our
edit site
relative to the wild type control you
know our unedited sample where we have
really nice clean reads
throughout the sample and so you can see
here kind of how
messy this data is and how our software
is able to kind of pull out
meaningful outcomes from this from this
messy data
going back to our results tab we can
look at any of these samples that way
so for example if i take you know kind
of this let's see here let's go to this
guy let's go to number one sample number
one
and we go to its in dell frequency chart
we can see yeah the majority
of the sequences we're pulling out are
still that position zero so really no
change 64 percent of that still being
wild type and then we've got
some minus one and then some other minor
variance here like
let's see here this is less than one
percent uh for this -10 position so
again
able to pull out kind of the main
editing result that came from this
particular guide rna
and allowing you to quickly screen and
see what kind of results
this guide rna is providing for you
now the second experiment type that
we're going to do and i'm going to start
a new project
load up is going to be clonal screening
and so if we switch our toggle over here
the software is going to kind of take in
different parameters for this analysis
but ultimately the setup is very similar
so i'm going to be loading in
our control file here so we drop in our
single control file
we're going to be dropping in 95 edited
samples here because we're going to be
screening an entire 96 well plate of
samples
you can see how fast that was uploaded
and is being validated by the software
and then i'm going to be importing a
mapping template from my computer
as well that's going to identify all of
those
particular samples so this is our clonal
mapping templates
and you can see for this example we have
our guide rna sequence which is
consistent for all of the results here
as well as a donor sequence that's been
incorporated here
to be used for doing a specific snip
change
for this particular example i'll go
ahead and click
analyze and it will do the analysis for
all 95 of these samples
all right and now we have our results
here we've got a very long table
a whole lot of results here that we need
to look at
but what's nice is that it's going to be
auto sorting this based on this grading
system that we've put into place
looking at that percent editing looking
at percent hdr
and that edit diversity so if we take a
look at kind of our our sample here that
was in well
h1 we can see that we've got some a very
clean result here so if we look at our
plate view we can see
in this 96.4 or excuse me 96 well plate
view
all of our our samples that we were
looking at we've got our blue ones that
are kind of maybe are less likely to be
successful samples
we've got our stars here which are going
to be our ideal case scenarios we've got
our control file here
we've got a well that's a true wild type
you know very low editing efficiencies
and we can see here are our kind of our
top of the list guy here
that has a model fit of one we've got
like almost we've got 100
editing efficiency and we've got that
diversity of edit being
one we've got only one outcome from this
and so we have you know we look at our
indel
frequency chart we have just that snip
change occurring we have a very clean
outcome here for the editing outcome
that we were looking for
if we go back to some of these other
examples here
you know we've got a diversity of edits
of two and i go and look at this indel
frequency chart
i can see that we have some examples
here where we have our successful
knock-in
with that snip change as well as some
other ones and some minor variants here
we've got that plus one insertion so
we've got fifty percent being
um having the snip correction done and
fifty percent
with this um excuse me with a single
base
insertion here um
let's see here let's see what i'm going
to do and then for reference here the
snip change that we're trying to do
just to make it super clear is at this
position here we're doing a c to g
mutation with this snip so we've got our
edit site here
and going back about nine bases i
believe we've got our snip change here
for our knock-in examples you can do a
donor to control alignment so you can
see
how well your donor lines up with your
control sample you can see that g to c
base being highlighted here those are
where our changes are so that we know
what our donor was specifically trying
to do
and then we can also see our sequencing
traces as well if you need to look at
that raw
data going back to our plate
overview here again we can look at a
glance at our 96 well plate and clearly
see
you know our strongest candidates from
our clonal isolation and moving them
forward
this is a has been a great powerful tool
for a lot of our custom services team um
that supports cell line model generation
and they were the alpha users for this
for this software and it
has definitely improved the efficiencies
of those systems so it's really a great
platform for that
and with that i'm going to switch back
to my powerpoint for some closing
remarks
and our q a just give me one second here
all right hopefully you guys can see my
powerpoint again and we'll just wrap up
here so again kind of uh to wrap things
up in as a summary
we have our true design genome editor
being able to support all of the design
input needs and take those
considerations for your experimental
needs
identify the appropriate sequences and
provide you kind of a complete solution
to have a successful edit
at the bench and then we have our seek
screener confirmation app
to be used kind of as an analysis tool
after your gene editing is done
for both primary screening kind of
understanding how well a guide rna is
going to be working how well your donor
is being incorporated into a pool
and then as well as supporting kind of
that clonal isolation and screening
workflow as well
when you need to be analyzing you know
dozens of possible clones and figuring
out which ones successfully have
your specific snip changes or specific
editing outcomes
and again in summary we did a quick
review of our genome editing
and the the r d data that went behind
this we did a demonstration of true
design genome editor
and then we wrapped up doing a
demonstration of the seek screener
gene edit confirmation app and with that
i thank everyone for
their attendance and looking forward to
answering your questions
all right that was great matt thank you
um we are just about at time but i'll go
ahead
and we'll fit in some of these questions
that have come in um
if you still have a question that you'd
like to ask you can still do so
um just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen i'll have matt
answer a few now but any of those
um that come in that we don't have time
to answer and then anything that gets
submitted
during the on-demand viewing period we
will address them
using the contact information you
provided at the time of your
registration
okay so matt there's a handful these i
will try to pick some that are going to
be most relevant to the biggest group
um here's one that i know i know we've
heard once or twice
um why do i have to log in to use these
tools
right yes so um both the true design and
the seek screener do live on our thermo
fisher connect platform
we do require registration
to access those it is not really our
intent
for it for for marketing purposes but we
do have the opportunity like i showed
for seek screener for that data to be
saved
on our cloud platform so that you can
access it
there's also a whole variety of other
applications that i did that i didn't
talk about in this presentation
and since this is kind of our larger
ecosystem of bioinformatics
tools they do require a login for that
just a reminder is just a first name
last name email and password
you don't need to be providing you know
kind of all of your institutional info
you know if you have a purchasing agent
that does stuff for you you know
obviously you can still go through those
channels
it's really just some basic identity
information um to access the tool and so
we hope that
that is uh suitable for you guys to
access the kind of the power here
right right um so one um
kind of sounds like a usability question
what is the difference between
knock out with indel and a deletion so i
think this is speaking to some of the
options
on the the true design tool right right
right
so what the deletion is trying
what we're supporting with the deletion
functionalities there
is to do a very targeted removal of
bases
now like the idea for that would be is
like if you just needed to remove a
series of amino acids and still keep the
rest of the functional protein
by the knockout by indels you can get
that outcome
but what's more likely to happen is that
indel is going to be disrupting the
reading frame and leading to a
completely
truncated protein or a bunch of missense
mutations that's going to lead to the
entire protein being degraded
the deletion settings there is really to
try to make that targeted
to do specific amino acid removals while
still keeping the larger functional
protein
and functional sequence intact so it's
kind of more of a precision removal of
dna
versus kind of the more of a blunt-ended
response of using you know using indels
to cause knockouts
got it and then the other distinction
then though i suppose is that
the knockout with indel is simply we're
making a cut and letting the cells
repair themselves
exactly yeah whereas the deletion uses
a donor it uses a donor yeah yeah no
thank you
no thank you for that yeah and you're
right so the the deletion where we're
doing those
specific amino acid removals is going to
have a donor included with that
uh to tell the cells kind of how this
needs to be repaired
um when you're doing this as an indel
it's in the absence of a donor
so the cell is just repairing it by that
non-homologous and joining
uh somewhat randomly depending on the
cell type
all right makes sense okay so here's one
for the second tool that you showed
um does seek screener only work on
sanger sequencing
yeah so seek screener is a sanger
sequencing analysis tool so it's
specifically for
uh doing data convolution from those
kind of base calls
that come out of the capillary
electrophoresis now it will
use any you know dot ab1 file that comes
out of any genetic analyzer it doesn't
have to be a
thermal fisher piece of equipment to do
that but it is specific
for stanger sequencing analysis of
genome
of gene editing events there are other
tools that are in development around the
next generation sequencing platform
and we hope to be sharing those with you
uh in some future webinars
excellent all right well we've gone a
little bit over hopefully some people
have hung in to hear their questions
answered
um no it's fine um so thanks again for
your time and showing us this
these great tools that are available we
also need to thank lab roots and our
sponsor thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
and then of course thanking the audience
for joining us today this webcast
is going to be able to be viewed on
demand so lab roots will alert you
by email when it's available for for
replay so please
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues or anyone who may
have missed
today's event that might be interested
and until then have a great day
it has a hard